a green hued comet on a 50 000 year
journey is making its closest approach
to Earth perhaps for the last time in
Qatar amateur astronomers enthusiasts
and students gathered in al-karara a
dark spot far from artificial lights to
photograph it Colin Baker has more
there are billions of comets in our
solar system a handful that passed by
the Earth every year and a few that
become so-called bright comets with
glowing heads and long tails last year a
new one was discovered as it passed the
orbit of Jupiter and right now if you
look North just after Sunset near the
Big Dipper constellation using
binoculars or a telescope you might just
be able to see it Comet 2022 E3 ztf
named after the telescope that saw it
and the time it was seen likely comes
from the distant Oort cloud a cosmic
mist of water ice and rock that sits
thousands of times further from our Sun
than Neptune it's one of two places
comets come from in our solar system
the last time this Comet appeared in our
Sky Earth was in an ice age and modern
humans were making Stone Age tools
alongside now extinct neanderthals and
denisovans
as any Comet approaches the sun it heats
up the Frozen material inside gets
thrown off as gas and dust that can be
seen streaking across the sky at the
front of this one a reaction that was
only recently understood is happening a
molecule of two carbon atoms burns green
before being destroyed by sunlight
comets may have brought water to Earth
in its early years
this one is expected to leave the sun's
pull entirely flying off into
Interstellar space
so seeing it really is a unique
opportunity